what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are continuing the Batman who
laughs miniseries and uh yeah okay I'm
I'll be honest man like let it sit the
same thing I said in the first in the
first issue like this is so cool and
jock is the one who okay so jock someone
doing the art those guys who don't know
I'm pretty sure jock was the one who did
the art for witches and if you guys
never read Scott Snyder switches you are
seriously missing out your Scout
Snyder's which is is ridiculously good I
can't wait to get into witches too but
it's it's it's pretty wild anyway so so
what are these to pick up on here and
kind of rehash cuz it's been a little
while been a few weeks since we did the
first one and we do a some catching up
to do
because I mean it is January so it's the
time of year we just kind of lay back
and just do like three videos a week or
something like that then we started
picking things back up again something
once we get into like February and March
with this whole idea of the Batman who
last the Batman who last was like the
most popular character to come out of
Dark Knight's metal right like I think
we can all agree on that but the Batman
who last was just resounding ly popular
because it was the answer to the
question what would happen if Batman
became the Joker and the idea behind
this is that the Batman who lasted
always just kind of been in the
background following Dark Knight's medal
he was never actually defeated and it
wasn't really until recently until this
miniseries that we actually have him
doing things he was kind of in the
beginning of immortal min a little bit
but he was more in the beginning of a
mortal man for the purpose of like
drawing in readership than actually
doing anything worthwhile but the long
and short of what we've seen so far just
in the first really the first the second
issue so far is that the Batman who last
has a plan we just don't know exactly
what it is but remember the entire basis
behind how the Batman who last became
what he was was when the Joker had
essentially been killed and then
released a kind of Joker toxin that
infected Bruce Wayne and turned him into
the Joker which turn him into the Batman
who lasts and so the idea is that when
Joker head of appears to Bruce Wayne at
the end of the first issue and then offs
himself then is essentially like okay
the Joker's like you're the only one who
can defeat the Batman who laughs you
have to become me in order to beat him
and then Joker basically tries to off
himself in an effort to like spread the
toxin out the difference here is that it
doesn't happen right off the bat because
of the fact that that Bruce Wayne is
aware of who the Batman who laughs is
and the origin story of his character
he's trying to like stem the flow and so
what's basically going on here is Bruce
is kind of transforming to trying to
keep it at bay
while the same time the Joker's being
worked on if the Joker dies but that's
when the toxin really gets released and
there's no coming back but in this
instance what Bruce Wayne has been doing
is literally pumping himself with every
kind of Joker toxin they have but that's
one of the important things to bear in
mind
here is it the toxin within the Joker's
heart is so potent that it can't really
beat stuff all the other versions of the
Joker toxin that exists out there those
have antidotes right that's what Bruce
Wayne's been using over the years is
using those antidotes to those versions
of the Joker toxin synthesizing and and
though if the toxin is new and then
using it to cure people this is a
perfect strain it's a perfect and pure
strain and so there is no antidote for
there's no conceivable way to overcome
it and so the best that Bruce can do is
stave it off and so while that's
happening what he's trying to do here is
understand what the Batman who laughs is
trying to do and so in the midst of all
this while all that's going on what we
end up having is some guy who's driving
and suddenly like a version of Bruce
Wayne lands on top of his car now this
breeze in Commissioner Gordon and it
brings in what appears to be Harvey
Bullock now with Commissioner Gordon
he's kind of working on the other half
of this case the first part of the case
kind of the front side is the Batman who
laughs is back what's his plan the back
side is all these different versions of
Bruce Wayne from what are basically what
seem to be like the Dark multiverse are
popping up now that's kind of the the
caveat here is initially it seemed to be
dark multiverse versions of Bruce Wayne
this does not appear to be true instead
what it seems to be our versions of
Bruce from across the multiverse not
versions of Bruce Wayne from the dark
multiverse and the reason why is because
with that multiverse itself it was
basically full of what like like
worst-case scenarios what if Superman
became a bad guy and killed everybody on
earth what if Batman became the Joker
and then became an evil version of
Batman like that's the kind of thing you
see in the dark multiverse this version
of Bruce like the other version who had
died and the other versions that have
appeared off panel that have been
discovered by Commissioner Gordon are
good versions of Bruce this one in
particular was actually mayor of Gotham
City the problem with this is that while
all that happens one of the rookies
basically walks up to Harvey Bullock
starts talking to him and Harvey Bullock
starts freaking out and that's when we
end up learning this is actually Bruce
Wayne with the Joker toxin and that's
what's so crazy about this is Bruce is
walking a knife's edge right now at any
moment he could fall over he could
literally flip over the other side and
become the Joker he's doing the best he
can D to kind of hold it together but
there's a limit to all this the other
half and this is this is one of the cool
things about Scott Snyder writing is
Bruce reveals something that we didn't
really know before and so one of the
things he does here is he draws what's
basically called the last laugh and the
idea was that if Gotham City were ever
attacked which is to say if it was like
a chemical weapon or if there was some
kind of toxin that was released across
the city or whatever it is but the city
itself just sort of fell into absolute
madness now there were all these tunnels
that have been designed over the years
basically allow for fast travel of like
food and supplies and means by which the
city could essentially be fixed but what
Bruce Wayne has been working on is his
own version of last life because the
fact of the Joker toxin is so so
powerful and presumably coming out of
the events of Batman in game one of the
things that Bruce Wayne devised is that
there had to be a means by which the
city could be cured he could literally
pump an antidote into the entire city
itself and cure everyone and so by
working on that one of the things he
says is that this is a system by which
Gotham can be saved but it's also a
system by which Gotham can be destroyed
and the initial response of Commissioner
Gordon is well then what's the huge
concern here and the response of Bruce
Wayne is to say that you can only access
it using DNA and that's when we pick up
with the Batman whoo laughs and that's
what's so great about this is because
the Batman who lasts is an evil version
of Bruce he essentially had all the same
experiences as Bruce Wayne up into the
point when the Joker died and he was hit
with the toxin and men went crazy and so
because he thinks he feels he functions
in the exact same way as Bruce Wayne in
the main DC Universe he would do the
exact same things Bruce would which
means he's he's aware of the exact same
things Bruce's and so that's when really
Snyder kind of tells us indirectly that
all these things that Bruce Wayne's
doing in the main DC Universe the Batman
who lasted in his universe and so with
that happening with that in mind Batman
who laughs shows up at Wayne Manor which
is the only access point to this last
laugh tunnel that Bruce Wayne's been
building and then in turn basically
begins to access it now the only real
guardian here is a guy named Bill and
the initial inclination is like how does
Bill not know this as Bruce Wayne only
for us to find out to Bill's blind as it
was kind of a cool thing because what
this would do is it would actually allow
Bruce Wayne to access this aspect of
Wayne Tower and for Bill to never really
know Bruce Wayne's face or at least to
never really know that it was actually
him now the fact that Bill refers to him
as mr. Wayne indicates that Bill knows
exactly who Bruce Wayne is and the
Batman who last makes his way in there
and when he does we see an aspect of his
character we don't normally see when it
comes to this version of Bruce and when
we saw him in Dark Knight's metal he was
really more like the second-in-command
he was a guy who was running alongside
Barbados but when you throw him into
this story what it does is it shows he's
just as capable as we would expect it's
all the formidable formidable abilities
of Bruce Wayne combined with the
insanity of the Joker which basically
makes for him going through and killing
every single member of Wayne security
inside this section of Wayne Tower with
no limits whatsoever one of the other
cool things here and a really kind of
under
or the fact that he and Bruce thinks so
much alike is that once all these guys
are dead he counts down and 3 2 1
BAM enters Batman and that's kind of the
cool thing here is because what it means
and what it really shows here is that
Roo Swain fighting this evil version of
himself that it really seems to be an
even match and in fact as this fight
unfolds Bruce comments on it proper that
he says well I'm stronger but I'm not
faster and so because of the fact that
he's able to fight so cable Bleek what
this means is he can overcome me because
of the fact that he knows exactly how I
function he knows the weaknesses he
knows what kind of weapons he needs in
order to overcome my various suits of
armor and the kind of defense mechanisms
that I employ and it's kind of a funny
thing here because Bruce gets the upper
hand on the Batman who lasts and when
Bruce Condon basically says like your
whole plan stops here the response about
I knew last is what makes you think this
is not part of my plan and that's the
cool that's what I loved so much about
his character it is Scott Snyder writes
him in such a way that you have to
assume everything that happens happens
according to the will of the Batman who
lasts that if he's defeated is because
he wanted to be defeated because he
wanted to be taken to a particular
location and he knew he would be taken
to that location if he was defeated
because he knows how Batman works as a
you have to assume that he knows
everything that's going to happen or at
the very least
has planned it all out ahead of time and
this all really comes to a head when
Bruce Wayne is shot and this is cool
because what Batman who laughs does as
he says there's basically this guy out
there this version of Bruce Wayne who's
out there he's called the grim knight
he's basically Batman as The Punisher
that this version of Bruce Wayne is far
more extreme and the way he came into
existence was by virtue of the fact that
when Joe chills shot Thomas and Martha
Bruce Wayne picked up a gun and shot Joe
Chill the implication seems to be that
Joe Chill shot Thomas and Martha and
then dropped the gun out of perhaps
panic or fear whatever the case was and
ran and in that moment Bruce Wayne
picked the gun up and shot Joe Chill and
that set him on the path of killing
every criminal he finds and so what
Batman who lasts does is kind of reveal
everything to Bruce and say you built
this entire place in order to ensure
that Gotham could be saved in the event
of an emergency by pumping out some
antidote how many uses as a means to
destroy the city and the response of
verse is well you can't do that because
the building can only really be used in
that regard if it's empty and the
response of many lashes I know
and all these safeguards that you have
in place have all been dismantled by the
Grimm Knight he's done it all over the
pillow for the last couple days so I'm
going to destroy this building and I'm
to destroy your ability to basically
save the city of Gotham in this moment
there's nothing that can be done there
nothing Bruce Wayne can do the best he
can do is escape he grabs bill he uses
one of those little wrapping hooks they
escape they escape Wayne Tower and the
entire building comes crashing down
around them and so what this means is
the means by which Gotham can be saved
based on whatever plan the Batman who
last has is gone there's no real way to
believe that it can be done in any real
measure of time because you have to
assume that whatever planet is the
Batman who last has whatever plan he has
has base is going to be predicated on
what Bruce Wayne would most likely do so
again overcoming the odds by knowing how
his enemy functions and so with Bruce
Wayne returning back to out to Wayne
Manor and running up to Alfred its wick
the Joker up you have to wake him up now
what we end up realizing here is Joker's
been awake the entire time he's been
listening to the discussions of Bruce
and Alfred and where he's been kind of
laughing and they've been assuming it's
a reaction in reality he's laughing at
the futility of their choices he's
laughing at the futility of their
efforts to try to stop the Batman who
lasts because the responsive you know
really with Bruce here the idea is you
have to know the answer you have to know
what it is that the Batman who lasts
wants he's basically you from an
alternate reality only you really seem
to be the one that knows how his mind
works tell me what he's going to do and
the response to the Joker is I don't
know what he's gonna do there's only one
person out there in the entire world who
knows exactly what it is a Batman who
last is going to do and that person is
none other than James Gordon jr. the son
of Commissioner Gordon and the guy who's
basically nuts without being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here two comments explain
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the Rob port if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I'm leaving you on
a cliffhanger I will explain James
Gordon jr. in the next video I will
catch you all later peace
[Laughter]
[Music]